[Music]
hey do we have any food hi my name is
amanda cerny
and if you're like me you're eating way
less meat or none at all um you know
what I think so let's see okay oh and
wait this is my Marilyn Monroe moment so
what are you supposed to do with all
this extra meat you got lying around
sorry well thanks to all the various
metals chemicals and other additives
found in industrial meat you can use it
for just about anything oh what's going
on in here oh you're just doing a thing
huh I was about to make lunch okay can
you just go away though I'll be done
soon okay okay let's go a lot of ground
beef is treated with ammonia a key
ingredient in industrial cleaners so you
can use it to make your home a school we
could clean filthy squeaky clean chicken
in the US House and the high-strength
chlorine bath which means your pool
maintenance just got a whole lot easier
oh no no we're good here isn't it hard
to get your whites to be their whitest
well not anymore thanks to shrimp
treated with bleaching powder perfect Oh
[Music]
crowd a medicine cabinet don't worry
a study found that chicken contain
Prozac and antihistamine a sex hormone
and caffeine so you can replace all that
what are you doing I am so sorry I
survived do you yes okay um well you can
just you sure you don't want it just in
case
a recent study has actually found you
and I depressing some wild-caught fish
and I mean if anything that's you really
turn that frown upside down la bonne
later hey here I made this for you well
that's so nice what the hell is this oh
you should drink more okay and don't
stop there imagine what you can do with
you
just for [ __ ] sake don't eat it
[Music]